[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing whether nagini voldemort's
faithful pet snake turned horcrux would
have turned evil if the dark lord hadn't
harbored a piece of his splintered soul
inside of her let's sink our teeth into
this one shall we all right so most of
you will know nakini from the original
harry potter novels and films she was an
enormous snake and an unquestionably
loyal servant of lord voldemort who he
often kept close at hand to help him
carry out his dirty work you know eating
the odd witch or wizard attacking
members of the order of the phoenix and
the likes of that of course as we find
out in the final installment of the
series nagini is also one of voldemort's
seven horcruxes which is likely another
reason he kept her nearby at all times
that was why according to albus
dumbledore at least anyway being that
voldemort born tom marvel riddle was a
descendant of salazar slytherin he
possessed the ability to speak parcel
tongue an extremely rare language that
but plainly meant that he could talk to
snakes
his ability to communicate with nagini
further shows why they would have had a
close bond and perhaps explains
voldemort's reasoning behind making
nagini a horcrux in the first place
here was a creature that he could speak
to but who wouldn't betray his
confidence in a way a human could but
wouldn't it be a bit dicey to literally
put your life in the hands the scales of
a snake well here's where nagini's
backstory gets interesting she actually
used to be a woman as jk rowling has
continued to expand the harry potter
universe since the release of the
deathly hallows in 2007 we've learned
more and more about characters who
weren't given the most substantial
backstories in the original series
nagini is one of those characters her
origin story was at last revealed
through the fantastic beasts movie
franchise the prequel film series to
harry potter in the second movie
installment fantastic beasts the crimes
of grindelwald we discovered that nagini
had not always been a snake she was in
fact at one time a human woman as a
woman she was a maledictus meaning she
was born with a blood curse that at
first allowed her to transform back and
forth between a human and a snake sadly
as with all maledictuses she eventually
lost the ability to control her
transformations and the affliction
ultimately trapped her in the form of a
serpent
this beastial version of the guinea was
of course the only one we used to know
the unusually intelligent and malevolent
pet serpent of lord voldemort
but with the telling of the guinea's
origin story we are shown the type of
woman she was before she became
voldemort's loyal pet and i wouldn't be
shocked if many of you like myself were
quite surprised to find that neghini was
not completely terrible as a human in
fact it would seem that she was actually
quite moral and good let me explain in
fantastic beasts the crimes of
grindelwald we are introduced to nagini
through credence away with wizard an
obscurial who is in search of clues to
his past
grince meets nagini after he joins a
travelling wizarding circus the circus
are carnis and the two form a close
friendship we witness nagini be kind and
compassionate towards credence and she
becomes concerned when he shows interest
in joining the powerful dark wizard
gelet grindelwald
ultimately despite caring for credence
nagini chooses to help the likes of newt
scamander and albus dumbledore in their
efforts to defeat grindelwald a far cry
from where she ends up with the
wizarding world's next great dark lord
voldemort which brings us to the
question if nagini was once a good and
kind woman how and when did she turn so
evil was it in fact when voldemort
turned her into his horcrux in all
honesty i rather think not here's why if
being made into a horcrux had the
ability to turn the vessel of the
horcrux into an evil creature or being
wouldn't harry potter have become
undeniably evil himself when voldemort
unintentionally turned him into one as a
baby
yes right but of course we know that
didn't happen even if harry wasn't a
full-on horcrux in fact we didn't even
know that harry was a horcrux until the
very end of the final installment of the
series he was a good wizard he was a
moral person who was maybe a little
stubborn and misguided at times but evil
harry never
so then why did nagini turn so evil if
not from being made into the dark lord's
horcrux i think the answer to that is
not a simple one
as a maledictus at first nagini had the
ability to go back and forth between her
two forms that of a woman and that of a
snake i wouldn't be surprised if she had
found it quite fascinating to start with
she may have even enjoyed it at one time
or another but once she permanently
became a snake can you imagine how
trapped and isolated she would have felt
knowing that she would never be able to
interact with the world as a human ever
again
she had no one to talk to no one to pass
a time with to be perfectly honest it
would be enough to make anyone go mad
really don't you think but then again
madness does not necessarily equate to
being evil
cue lord voldemort okay so how exactly
did nagini and voldemort meet her a
maledictus serpent and he a phantom-like
version of himself due to his failed
attempt to murder an infantary well the
theory goes that deep in the forest of
albania nakini met the shadowy remains
of the dark lord it was here that he was
rumored to have befriended many of the
animals that he came across in the woods
which of course included nagini and so
finally she had found someone or
something with whom she could
communicate voldemort who could speak to
her in parcel tongue was also able to
inhabit her body it's not that
far-fetched to think that an
impenetrable bond would have formed
especially on the guinea's behalf and so
nakini having been driven a little bit
mad due to her isolation from humanity
and living in the woods as a beast
likely would have been all too open to
well whatever her new best mate
voldemort suggested
especially if it included her sticking
with him when he left the forest of
albania
this would have been a very unique maybe
even once in a lifetime opportunity for
nagini an opportunity for her to rejoin
the wizarding world in a way she
probably hadn't thought possible before
meeting voldemort after all parcel
tongue was an incredibly rare language
and yet it was this wizard who could
understand and talk to her i can only
imagine this would have come as an
intense relief for nakini from there
well we know the rest nagini became
voldemort's most loyal pet it was nagini
who helped him regain his strength while
in his shadow form her venom was a key
part of the potion that enabled him to
return to temporary body and then nagini
herself was made into a horcrux further
helping him return to power when
voldemort took the life of bertha
jawkins
after that they were rarely separated
she witnessed him before murder after
murder and she killed on his behalf and
was constantly all of this clearly shows
that the guinea most certainly did turn
evil but i believe she did so long
before becoming one of voldemort's
horcruxes and so in my opinion nikki
still would have become evil even if she
hadn't been made into a horcrux she may
have even turned evil without having met
this particular dark lord after all
maledictus has lost the ability to think
like a human as time went on so it's
possible that she may have become more
and more wicked as she lived life
permanently as a snake but since it's
not inevitable for maledictus to become
evil despite the affliction coming from
a blood curse i think the main reason
the guinea turned evil was her
relationship with voldemort rather than
any form of magic blood curse horcrux or
otherwise in her desperation to connect
with her being more intelligent than the
woodland creatures she lived amongst in
the forest of albania she was willing to
be whatever the dark lord needed her to
be and that just so happened to be an
evil serpent willing to do his bidding
which brings us to the end of this video
what do you guys think do you agree that
it was nagini's relationship with
voldemort that turned her evil or do you
think she was already poised and ready
to be evil on her own when he met her or
was it something else entirely let me
know your thoughts in the comments below
and don't forget to like the video and
subscribe to the channel
until next time
dinner nagini
you